richard darveau j'ai depuis sedan chef
de la direction de l'association
québécoise de la quincaillerie schneider
vous est ce que vous pensez d'abord que
ça va continuer à monter
malheureusement oui c'est pas demain que
ça va descendre pourquoi parce que on
est sur les blocs de départ de la
relance économique et ça ça veut dire
que les municipalités les états
provinciaux nationaux
et puis le secteur privé attendre
jusqu'au qu'on soit rendu un certain
taux de vaccination pour être encore
plus agressif sur sur le marché 1 sur
les marches en général et puis donc le
bois et les autres matériaux de
construction seront encore plus en
demandant s'il ya plus de demandes
peut-être que de rareté ça donne
l'occasion pour pour ceux qui les
fabriquent de te contrôler les prix
élevés en poche le magot actuellement à
ce que les producteurs l'ont reconnu
dans le reportage
c'est une extraordinaire année pour eux
est ce que le gros de l'augmentation va
chez le producteur chez vous elle est ce
qu'ils vendent aux entrepreneurs qui
empoche le magot bon alors il faut
distinguer le bois d autres matériaux si
on isole votre question par rapport à
l'approvisionnement en bois
les scieries on dit prix qui sont qui
font beaucoup plus leur affaire
aujourd'hui mais il faut dire qu'ils ont
eu de très mauvaise année pendant deux
décennies alors autant avant c'était
peut-être sous leur prix de revient ils
ont eu des années à perte
aujourd'hui même conviennent que les
prix sont un peu fort puis dans votre
reportage on disait qu'on va sûrement
arriver un peu plus juste prix pour
toutes les parties
pensées vers le conte sans voix mais
dans les autres matériaux monsieur roy
sait d'autres problématiques c'est
d'autres raisons on se rend compte qu'on
est vulnérable par rapport à certaines
crises sociales on sent les deux que le
conflit qui va peut être revenir au port
de montréal on se souvient du blocage
des voies non mais je vais arriver je
vais arriver pour qu'on soit clair je
vais arriver aux autres parce que
effectivement il ya des pénuries de de
plusieurs produits mais je la planche
plat et au delà le contreplaqué qui
rendu à 100 dollars entre en pissant la
jeu
ce bien comprend vous dites c'est le
producteur qui en prend la plus grosse
part parce que il ya eu des années de
vaches maigres ou quoi oui absolument et
puis le prix est un peu trop élevé mais
de l'avis de l'ensemble des parties je
pense qu'on ne paye peut-être pas assez
cher pendant des années il faut juste
s'habituer ça ressemble aussi aux
valeurs des maisons parfois les
saoudiens une époque encore des fois les
producteurs de pétrole est foireux
tiennent le pétrole en sortent moins
pour monter le prix est ce que les cours
sont pleines ce qu'on retient du
matériel à huang pas mais on va
privilégier les clients réguliers alors
si vous présentez que vous êtes vous
arrivé comme un cheveu sur la soupe
ça se peut qu'on vous dise non même s'il
ya du bois disponible parce qu'on leur a
réservé pour les clients qui vous sont
fidèles et ça je pense que c'est très
c'est des bonnes affaires
les gens qui se demandent est ce qu'on
devrait se garder du bois au québec
est-ce qu'on devrait pas garder du stock
parce qu'on a un export beaucoup du bois
la moitié est exportée aux états unis à
peu près est-ce qu'on devrait pas se
regarder davantage qu'est ce que j'en
pensais absolument nous on est d'avis
que l'on doit sécuriser nos
approvisionnements et on pense que le
bois on devrait les levées à un niveau
qu'on appelle le bien commun ce n'est
plus une commodité comme n'importe quel
produit transigée à la bourse est
tellement essentiel et en particulier
pour soutenir la relance que l'on
souhaite leur une fois la vaccination
complété alors on demande au
gouvernement de trouver des façons de en
fait de s'asseoir avec l'ensemble des
joueurs pour dans l'urgence convenir de
mécanismes qui nous permettraient de
sécuriser nos besoins en bois en
particulier
donc ça veut dire réserver les forêts
publié un court et est ce que des
rencontres prévues ascad édition prévue
bientôt
oui on a des rencontres prévues avec
plusieurs cabinets ministériels dans les
heures et les jours qui viennent non
seulement vous êtes peut-être bien
informée et puis je pense que
l'ensemble avoir leur est très ouverte
non pas cette doléance parce que porte
ce n'est pas négatif c'est très positif
de demander d'être un peu plus à un
contrôle de certains produits clés mais
qui manque de pompe à caraman de chez
nous oui absolument
et puis tout comme on a peut-être trop
vous vouliez arriver peut-être sur cet
autre sujet on a trop délocaliser
certains composants clés qui font qu'il
ya des usines qui ne tourne pas dans
d'autres secteurs névralgiques dans la
peinture dans les portes et fenêtres
dans l'industrie de l'alcool
oui vous écoute mais justement je vais
arriver là je mets donc pour finir pour
le bois le rôle des quincailliers le
rôle des bannières est ce que eux en
profitent donc aussi vos mains il pour
cent mètres plus il ya plus de profits
en volume les affaires sont bonnes mais
l'image son plus petit qu'à pareille
date l'année dernière ça je peux vous le
dire de 10 marchand qui j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui de bagnères différence des
grands des moyens des petits en ville
comme montréal les ils sont tellement
gêné eux-mêmes d'acheter beaucoup plus
cher que ils se prennent des mange
tripes mais c'est pas un problème leçon
il faut pop3 l'argent qu'un volume et le
hockey bon on y arrive
monsieur d'amour dit le bois c'est une
chose mais il manque de lavabos ou une
autre de porter marque de fenêtres il
manque de tuer au manque de double oui
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'on est
aussi vulnérable par rapport aux crises
sociales mais aussi par rapport aux
changements climatiques
vous savez il ya eu une vague de froid
au texas à la mi-février ça nous
apparaît anodin pour pour nous qui
vivons au québec mais la bosse alors au
sens littéral gelé tous toute la
production est on en souffre encore ici
il ya beaucoup d' usine québécoise de
portes et fenêtres de fabrication de
peintures de cole chercher des boîtes
pour déménager l'on va approcher du 1er
juillet puis à ce que vous avez de la
difficulté à retrouver parce qu'un des
éléments là dedans c'est la colle
différents types de sous produits
chimiques qui sont concentrées ailleurs
qu'au québec qu'on produisait avant par
exemple en peinture on a des deux usines
de dylan et puis on les a on les a pas
appuyer on les a pas accompagné elles
ont fini par nous quitter alors je pense
que c'est ce qu'il ya de bon avec
l'apport des missiles si je peux me
permettre c'est que ça nous fait
réfléchir
peut-être en grappes pour employer une
expression qui paye cher à gerald
tremblay on doit revoir la notion de
fidélité entre clients et fournisseurs
pensée circuits courts par région par
secteur économique pour arrêter de
croire que parce qu'on économise
quelques quelques sous noirs en
délocalisent délocalisant un composant
au bout du monde qu'on se rend service
quand tu arrives des augmentations de
demande
on aimerait plus solide à leysin les uns
des autres et on était dans le
juste-à-temps le faut aller dans le
juste au cas parce qu'on ne sait pas
quelle encre et sociale climatique
économique va nous arriver c'est
intéressant et vous avez en tête toutes
sortes de produits quand vous dites cela
juste au cas qu'on produise davantage
une pléiade de produits
oui qu'on se rencontre pour voir où sont
nos sous traitants puis l'économie court
terme nouveaux hôtels encore la peine et
qu'on se solidarise à l'intérieur des
régions
c'est un appel qu'on fait le
gouvernement pour nous accompagner dans
ce dans ce travail ceux qui ont des
rénovations qui sont pas encore entamés
vous leur dites attendait dans une année
dense non non non mais non parce que la
prochaine ils vont voyager
alors même si c'est un peu cher you des
matériaux disponibles magazine est un
peu plus mais n'ont profité à vous avez
rien faire rien d'autre à faire on est
très bien je darveau président chef de
la direction de l'association québécois
des quincaillerie et des matériaux de
construction merci nous aurons parle du
fort intéressant merci